... nicht so ...
Hol Papier, sonst läuft es hinunter.
Ah! Ei, ei, ei!
Oh! Uff!
Künstliches Blut ...
(Kinder) Oh!
... Stichflammen ...
Gut!
... und Feuerbälle.
Nicht zu stark!
Es ist Projektwoche an der
Zürcher Privatschule Talenta.
* Knall *
(Kinder) Oh ...
Ich glaube, die Freude,
die man über einen Versuch hat,
fast das Wichtigste von allem ist.
Freut man sich an etwas,
ist man motiviert.
Alles andere kommt dann von selbst.
Es ist hier nicht meine Aufgabe,
dass ich an der Tafel Chemie mache
und irgendwelche Formeln
aufschreibe,
sondern dass die Kinder
schauen und ausprobieren können.
Alle Kinder, die hier zur Schule
gehen, haben etwas gemeinsam:
Sie sind hochbegabt.
* Lautes Reden im Hintergrund *
Mehr reingeben.
(Mädchen) Es wird gelb. Oho!
(Mädchen) Das ist mega cool!
D.h., sie haben einen IQ
von 130 oder mehr
und lernen darum viel schneller
als Gleichaltrige.
Wow! Das ist mega schön!
(Mehrere Kinder) Zwei, eins, los!
Damit sie ihr intellektuelles
Potenzial ausschöpfen können,
werden sie hier gezielt gefördert.
* Spannende Musik *
* Stimmengewirr, spannende Musik *
* Die Kinder reden durcheinander. *
(Junge) Cool!
- (Junge) Es wird heiss, es dampft.
Jetzt wird es heiss.
- (Junge) Cool!
Oho, das geht schnell rauf!
Michelle ist zehn.
Wir brauchen mehr W...
Wir brauchen mehr Wasser.
Die intellektuelle Überfliegerin
aus dem Glarnerland
ging gerne in den Kindergarten
und freute sich auf die Schule.
Dort begannen allerdings
bald die Probleme.
Michelle war unterfordert
und verlor das Interesse am Lernen.
Das änderte sich erst,
als sie an die Talenta wechselte.
Was gefällt dir hier?
* Sie lacht. *
Ähm ...
Dass jeder ...
... seine Schwierigkeitsstufe
haben darf.
Jeder kann so schnell arbeiten,
wie er es kann.
Und dass nicht die ganze Klasse
alles zusammen macht.
In deiner alten Schule
konnte man das nicht?
Nein, wir machten das Meiste als
Klasse, jeder hatte denselben Stoff.
Es geht weiter.
Warst du immer viel schneller
als die anderen?  - Ja.
Was hast du gemacht,
wenn du fertig warst?
Ähm, gewartet.
Ja ...
Ich musste halt warten.
War das langweilig?
- Ja.
Heute macht ihr Schule wieder Spass.
* Bravorufe *
* Kichern *
(Junge) Jemand von uns muss ...
* Sanfte Klavierklänge *
Michelle machte in der Volksschule
nie Hausaufgaben.
Bei den Prüfungen
war sie trotzdem immer die Beste.
Ganz so einfach
geht es nun nicht mehr.
Musst du lernen oder geht
alles immer noch von alleine?
V.a. am Anfang ist es schwierig.
Man muss sich daran gewöhnen, dass
man mehr Zeit für die Dinge braucht
und dass man früh genug
damit beginnt.
Das war schwierig für mich,
aber irgendwann ging es.
Du musstest lernen, dass man
für die Schule lernen muss.
Kann man das so sagen?
- Ja, das kann man so sagen.
* Langgezogene, schwermütige Klänge *
In der Volksschule
fehlte der sensiblen Michelle
nicht nur die intellektuelle
Herausforderung,
sie fand auch keinen Anschluss.
* Langgezogene Klavierklänge *
Von vielen wurde ich
auch gar nicht beachtet
oder sie sagten fiese Dinge zu mir
wie z.B. Streber.
Irgendwann
kam dann auch Mobbing dazu.
Mobbing?
- Ja, Mobbing.
Was war passiert?
- Also ...
Wahrscheinlich
waren andere Kinder eifersüchtig,
weil ich so schnell lerne
und die Sachen schnell verstehe.
Dann versucht man immer,
die anderen runterzumachen,
um selbst weiter oben zu sein.
Das hat irgendwann angefangen.
Was haben sie gemacht?
Jemand hat mich mal geschlagen,
also mir eine Ohrfeige verpasst.
Und sie haben angefangen,
fiese Dinge zu sagen.
Und, ja ...
Das war wohl keine einfache Zeit?
Nein.
Es ging mir oft schlecht
und ich musste viel weinen.
Mich hat es auch viele Tränen
gekostet, weil ich mitgelitten habe.
Sie war nicht mehr mein fröhliches,
aufgestelltes Kind.
Sie wurde immer ruhiger
und trauriger.
Ich habe gemerkt,
dass sie Freude hatte,
wenn wir ihr zu Hause
geistige Nahrung gegeben haben.
Die hat sie freudig aufgesogen.
Es war für sie nur noch schlimm,
in die Schule zu gehen.
Jacobers haben vier Kinder.
Nach
Michelle kamen noch drei Mädchen.
Inzwischen sind die Drillinge
fünf Jahre alt.
Julia, Vanessa und Jasmin.
Michelle und ihre drei Schwestern
verstehen sich gut -
meistens jedenfalls.
* Rascheln *
Wann nerven sie?
Wenn ich nicht da bin, gehen sie
manchmal einfach in mein Zimmer.
Es sind auch schon
ein paar Sachen kaputt gegangen.
(Mädchen, im Hintergrund)
Mami, was ist das? - Pst!
Und am Morgen kann man ...
Früher konnte man nicht ausschlafen,
weil sie ziemlich laut sind.
Aber es ist auch cool:
zum Spielen und so.
Spielst du gerne mit ihnen?
- Mhm.
* Scheppern *
Sehr speziell verlief indes Michelles
kurze Zeit in der Volksschule:
Sie begann zu schwänzen,
zog sich zurück.
Und ihr Gemüt
verdunkelte sich zusehends.
Eine schwierige Zeit
für die ganze Familie.
Man war sehr oft verzweifelt.
Wenn man das eigene Kind leiden
sieht, möchte man ihm helfen.
Und man wusste nicht,
wie man helfen könnte.
Die Schulpflicht gibt es,
da muss sie durch.
Wir konnten ihr einzig
in der Freizeit etwas bieten.
Das wog den langweiligen Schulalltag
aber nicht auf.
In einem gewissen Sinne
war man hilflos, ihr zu helfen.
In der Schule
kann man nicht reinreden.
Darum konnte man ihr in dieser Zeit
nicht wirklich helfen.
Der erste Schritt zur Lösung war,
Michelle gehört zu den 2 % der
Bevölkerung, die hochbegabt sind.
Joelle Huser ist spezialisiert
auf die Abklärung von Hochbegabten.
Sie verfasst seit 20 Jahren Gutachten
und gibt Empfehlungen ab.
In ihrer Praxis erlebt sie
immer wieder Familien,
die am Rande ihrer Kräfte sind.
Die Eltern melden ihre Kinder an.
Häufig, weil es schon Probleme gibt.
Das fängt damit an,
dass es im Kindergarten
Bauch- oder Kopfschmerzen hat.
Bei den Mädchen ist es häufig so,
dass sie sich zurückziehen.
Bei den Jungen ist es häufiger so,
dass sie aggressiv werden.
Unterforderung ist,
körperlich gesehen,
Unterforderung führt zu Stress.
Langandauernder Stress
führt zu Krankheit
und körperlichen Symptomen,
wie ich sie erwähnt habe:
Kopfschmerzen, Bauchschmerzen.
Alle möglichen
psychosomatischen Erkrankungen
können eine Folge
von Unterforderung sein.
* Schuss *
Nicolas ist zwölf - und hochbegabt.
Er liebt Herausforderungen.
* Schuss *
* Schuss, Klicken *
Regelmässig trainiert er bei den
Sportschützen Zürich-Aussersihl.
Mir gefällt, dass man sich
konzentrieren muss.
Das hilft mir
auch in der Schule ein bisschen.
Ich bin dadurch konzentrierter.
Ich habe das bemerkt,
als ich damit angefangen habe.
Es ist ein schöner Sport:
Man kann sich mit anderen messen
und an regionalen Wettkämpfen
teilnehmen.
Misst du dich gerne mit anderen?
- Ja, sehr.
Und am liebsten gewinnen?
- Ja.
Wie gehst du damit um,
wenn du verlierst?
Dann geht es das nächste Mal besser.
* Der Reporter lacht. *
Bevor seine Hochbegabung erkannt
wurde, fiel seinen Eltern auf,
dass er zusehends
unkonzentrierter wurde.
Nicolas war oft müde
und klagte über Bauchschmerzen.
Da muss ich gegen einen schiessen,
der 50 Punkte hat.
Diese hat 49.
Seine Probleme
lösten sich in Luft auf,
als er an die Talenta
wechseln konnte.
Er blühte auf -
und plant bereits seine Zukunft.
Dann ist bereits Schluss.
Welchen Weg möchtest du machen?
Im Moment ist Architekt
mein Wunschberuf.
Ich möchte sehr gerne
Architekt werden.
Ich bin offen für Änderungen.
Sollte es anders werden,
ist es nicht schlimm.
* Hämmernde, pulsierende Musik *
Tschüss, Papi!
- Fahr gut!
Tschüss!
- Schönen Morgen.
* Hämmernde, pulsierende Musik *
Michelle ist die Erste,
die sich bei Familie Jacober
am Morgen auf den Weg macht.
Sie pendelt jeden Tag vom
Glarnerland in die Stadt Zürich -
und am Abend wieder zurück.
Man muss früher aufstehen und
hat weniger Zeit, aber es geht gut.
Möchtest du morgens
nicht auch lieber schlafen?
Doch!
Schon einige Male.
* Hämmernde, pulsierende Musik *
Am Anfang sei es komisch gewesen,
Michelle alleine
auf den langen Schulweg zu schicken,
erzählen die Eltern.
Inzwischen ist es tägliche Routine.
Die ersten paar Male
waren die Eltern auch noch dabei,
damit ich den Weg kennenlernte.
Aber es ist ziemlich gut gegangen.
Natürlich hat man immer etwas Angst,
ein Zug könnte ausfallen.
Das habe ich eigentlich immer ...
Ist es schon vorgekommen?
- Ja.
Was hast du dann gemacht?
Nach Hause telefoniert und
sie haben mir ein wenig geholfen.
Es ist gegangen.
Am Ende hat es geklappt?
- Ich bin nach Hause gekommen.
* Hämmernde, pulsierende Klänge *
Im Tram trifft sie eine Kollegin,
die sie von der Schule kennt: Xenia.
Bei der Intelligenz
spielen Gene eine grosse Rolle.
Sie legen
unser Intelligenzpotenzial fest.
Damit dieses Potenzial
zum Tragen kommt,
muss allerdings die Umgebung stimmen.
* Vereinzelte, abfallende Töne *
(Tonband, Frau) One.
- (Tonband, Mann) Spider.
(Kinder) Spider.
(Tonband, Frau) Ten.
- (Tonband, Mann) Frog.
(Kinder) Frog.
Viele dieser Kinder haben einen
längeren Leidensweg hinter sich,
fühlten sich als eine Art Aliens
in der Volksschule.
Hier machen sie
zum ersten Mal die Erfahrung,
keine Aussenseiter zu sein.
(Joelle Huser)
Es ist für diese Kinder,
die anders sind als die Norm,
extrem wichtig für ihre
sozial-emotionale Entwicklung,
dass sie immer wieder mit ähnlich
denkenden und fühlenden Kindern
zusammenkommen.
Das kann auch ausserhalb
der Schule sein.
Es gibt den Verein
für Eltern hochbegabter Kinder,
der regelmässig
solche Angebote macht.
Es kann auch eine Spezialschule sein
oder es kann auch
ein Pull out sein.
Das sind wichtige Gefässe,
in welchen diese Kinder merken:
"Wir gehören dazu."
Und es kann normal sein,
so zu denken und zu fühlen.
Es gibt Kinder,
die Mühe haben in der Schule,
weil sie nicht mitkommen.
Es gibt auch ein paar wenige, die
Mühe habe, weil sie zu begabt sind.
Für sie gibt es jetzt eine Lösung.
In der Stadt Zürich beginnt ein für
die Schweiz einmaliges Experiment
Hochbegabte Kinder können
eine Sonderklasse besuchen.
Heute war Schulanfang.
Begonnen hat die Talenta 1998
mit einem einzigen Schulzimmer
und einer einzigen Klasse,
bestehend aus neun Kindern
zwischen
sieben und zehn Jahren.
Der Gegenwind aus der staatlichen
Bildungswelt war erheblich.
Dass Hochbegabte unter sich
sein sollen, war vielen suspekt.
Über 20 Jahre später hat die Talenta
ein eigenes Schulhaus
im zürcherischen Kreis 6
und unterrichtet etwa 50 Kinder.
(Xaver Heer) Das ist unser Werkraum,
etwas improvisiert,
aber es funktioniert.
Ist das hier alles
ein kreatives Chaos?
Ja, man kann es so sagen.
Man muss sich einfach wohlfühlen.
Ein Ordnungsfanatiker
hätte es hier schwer.
Xaver Heer ist studierter Biologe,
zudem ausgebildeter
Primar- und Gymnasiallehrer.
Er hat die Talenta gegründet
und leitet sie bis heute.
Er hat selber einen hochbegabten
Sohn und musste feststellen,
dass es keine
massgeschneiderten Angebote gab,
sehr wohl aber eine Nachfrage.
Das Schulzimmer der Gruppe grün.
Das sind meistens
zwischen zwölf und 14 Kindern,
die hier zusammen sind.
* Hohe, kristallene Klänge *
Ist jedes schwierige Kind
ein hochbegabtes Kind?
Oh, nein! Nein, nein.
Es ist ein Irrtum, zu glauben, wenn
ein Kind in der Schule blöd tut,
dass es hochbegabt sein muss.
Das ist einfach nicht wahr.
Ähm ...
Es gibt sicher manchmal
solche Merkmale.
Die Kinder wissen nicht,
was sie in der Klasse machen sollen.
Dann benehmen sie sich anders
oder holen sich
irgendwelche Aufmerksamkeiten.
Aber generell
lässt sich das so nicht sagen.
Was man laut Heer
auch nicht sagen kann:
dass nur hochbegabt ist, wer beim
IQ-Test mind. 130 Punkte erreicht.
Der IQ-Test ist wichtig,
wir wollen ihn von jedem Kind,
aber er ist
nicht alleine entscheidend.
Sie müssen sich immer vorstellen:
Der Streubereich ist sehr gross.
Man kann nicht sagen, jemand mit
einem IQ von 130,0 ist hochbegabt
und jemand mit 129,9 nicht.
Es ist ein Witz,
wenn man diese Tests so auffasst.
Ich bin zu stark
von den Naturwissenschaften geprägt,
um so etwas einfach
als Zahl zu nehmen. Das geht nicht.
Die Talenta ist nicht mehr
die einzige Schule für Hochbegabte.
Das Angebot ist gewachsen - und
steht quer in der Bildungslandschaft.
In der Pädagogik
geben die Befürworter einer
inklusiven Beschulung den Ton an.
Hochbegabte, Minderbegabte
und alle dazwischen
sollen in die gleiche Klasse gehen.
Keinen ausschliessen,
alle einschliessen.
Inklusion statt Exklusion.
Für Hochbegabte sollen spezielle
Angebote in der Volksschule reichen.
Ich weiss nicht,
ob es wirklich Inklusion ist,
wenn das Kind
wieder zig Stunden rausgeht
und dort zu einem Förderlehrer geht
und dieses und jenes speziell macht.
Diese Kinder -
ich weiss das einfach -
haben z.T. Probleme,
weil sie so zum Aussenseiter werden,
weil sie dauernd
ein anderes Programm haben,
das nichts mehr
mit der Klasse zu tun hat
und sie sind z.T.
ausserhalb der Klasse.
Das ist auf eine Art
auch nicht mehr sinnvoll.
Die Talenta sondere Hochbegabte ab
und bringe sie
um wichtige Lernerfahrungen
im Umgang mit sozialer Vielfalt,
argumentieren Heers Kritiker.
Ich glaube,
das hat auch damit zu tun,
dass man in der Schweiz
Angst vor einer Elitebildung hat.
Wir reden auch
vom goldenen Mittelweg,
nicht vom goldenen Höhenweg.
* Lachen *
Ich finde, dass das einiges über
unsere Schweizer Mentalität sagt:
um keinen Preis auffallen,
sich in der Mitte bewegen.
Das ist sicher mitprägend.
Die grossen Ressourcen
von intellektuell begabten Kindern
und Erwachsenen
stehen leider zu wenig im Fokus.
Und jetzt pusten! Pusten! Pusten!
Gut. Noch einmal hineinhalten!
Kinder wie Nicolas sind Ausnahmen.
Rund 70 % der Hochbegabten
bleiben in der Volksschule.
Das Überspringen von Klassen
in Kombination mit Förderprogrammen
reicht meist völlig.
Aber es gibt
offensichtlich auch Kinder,
die erst in Heers Unterricht
wieder glücklich werden.
Ich besuchte anderthalb Jahre die
öffentliche Schule bei uns im Dorf.
Die war eigentlich auch sehr schön.
Das Schulkonzept
hat mir nicht gefallen
und es hat für mich nicht gepasst.
Wer hier zu Schule gehen will,
braucht intellektuelle Ressourcen,
aber auch finanzielle.
Die Talenta ist eine Privatschule
und kostet rund 2'000 Fr. pro Monat.
Wir haben intensiv
nach Sponsoren gesucht.
Wir sind leider
nicht fündig geworden.
Es ist so, dass gewisse
Schulgemeinden ein Kind übernehmen,
wenn sie sehen, dass es keine
anderen Möglichkeiten mehr gibt.
Es ist sicher nicht wünschenswert,
dass es so teuer ist,
aber wir haben keine andere Wahl.
Wir haben Räumlichkeiten,
die uns sehr viel Geld kosten.
Wir zahlen unsere Lehrer so, wie
wenn sie an der Volksschule wären.
* Die Kinder reden durcheinander. *
Auf die Plätze, fertig - los!
Nur einmal zünden
und dann sein lassen.
Die Schweiz kompensiert ihren Mangel
an natürlichen Rohstoffen
seit je mit grossen Anstrengungen
zur Steigerung der Innovationskraft.
Gleichzeitig wird die Begabten-
förderung stiefmütterlich behandelt.
Das grosse Geld
geht zu jenen Kindern,
die wirklich Schwächen haben.
Ich möchte das absolut
nicht infrage stellen
Ich finde, es braucht
zwei verschiedene Kassen.
Es gibt wirklich
auch diese Vorurteile, die sagen,
dass sich bei Kindern
mit besonderen Begabungen
diese Begabung
von alleine durchsetzt.
Das ist einfach nicht so.
Sie ticken anders,
sie haben andere Bedürfnisse.
Sie haben besondere Bedürfnisse.
Auch sie haben das Recht,
adäquat gefördert zu werden
und nicht nur erkannt,
sondern anerkannt zu werden.
* Heitere Klänge, Stimmengewirr *
Nicolas' Zeit an der Talenta
ging diesen Sommer zu Ende.
Er hat
ans öffentliche Gymnasium gewechselt.
Es wird Hürden geben.
Man wird sehen, ob der Weg
über oder um die Hürden führt,
aber man muss sie nehmen.
Das Wichtigste ist, dass er
ein glückliches Leben haben wird.
Er soll neugierig
und wissbegierig bleiben.
Wir unterstützen ihn dabei gerne.
Nicolas startet mit viel Optimismus
in seinen neuen Lebensabschnitt.
Über den Wind
können wir nicht bestimmen,
das weiss er als angehender Skipper,
aber wir können die Segel richten.
* Entspannte Musik *
Es konnte noch niemand beweisen,
dass wir etwas Schlechtes machen.
Unseren Kinder geht es gut,
was auch eine Untersuchung zeigte.
Wir liessen die Befindlichkeit
der Kinder anschauen.
Das ist absolut gut.
Man konnte zeigen,
dass sie innert sechs Monaten -
seit sie bei uns sind -
ihre Befindlichkeit um sehr viele
Prozentpunkte verbessern konnten.
Solange das so ist, ist es
eigentlich in Ordnung. Oder?
* Stimmengewirr *
* Fröhliche Musik *
Jasmin, ist es gut so?
(Mädchen) Hui!
Wir haben unsere aufgestellte,
fröhliche Tochter wieder,
die auch Freude am Lernen hat.
Sie ist wieder ein aufgestelltes
Mädchen, wie man es sich wünscht.
Es ist schlagartig gegangen.
In der ersten Woche in der Talenta
ist sie extrem aufgeblüht.
Achtung, fertig - los!
Der Wechsel an die Talenta
hat aber noch mehr bewirkt:
Er hat Michelle damit versöhnt,
dass sie anders ist als die meisten,
nämlich hochbegabt.
Ist das für dich eher positiv
oder ist es eher eine Last?
Es ist eher positiv:
Ich habe die Gabe,
etwas schnell zu lernen und
auch schnell verstehen zu können.
* Fröhliche Musik,
aufgedrehtes Lachen *
Lausmädchen!
* Hektische Musik, Stimmengewirr *
SWISS TXT AG / Access Services
Andrea Werlen - 2019
Willst du mir helfen?
Daneben!
Schiessen! Schiessen!